handsome guys my name is Archana welcome
to the third Sparky
dev vlog so we're gonna be talking about
a lot of stuff today because I haven't
done a dev vlog for the past two weeks
for various circumstances but rest
assured I have been hard at work and
I've done quite a lot of I'm still
working on quite a lot so basically this
developers gonna be something that is
going to be showing stuff that is very
much in progress stuff that isn't done
yet stuff that stuff probably doesn't
look right or perform correctly or you
know the API is all over the place all
that kind of stuff like this is code
that is kind of dodgy right now and it's
very much in progress but of course the
dev vlog did come up I tried to kind of
clean stuff up before this dev vlog but
I didn't want to miss another devlog so
you guys gonna be seeing this stuff as
it is and it should be pretty cool so
first things first if you actually go to
the github repository and you look at
the Kamiya's it'll appear that I haven't
actually committed anything in a really
long time in fact 20 days ago was the
last time I committed something and I
don't remember if I mentioned this stuff
in the last day vlog but it was
basically lighting things and I've done
a lot since then now what I've done is
the major features that I that I started
in fact you can all see this on the
Sparky Trello board was forward
rendering I was kind of working a lot on
that and also physically based rendering
okay now those are two pretty Jayant
asks and essentially I Technic I usually
use multiple computers when developing
things for example I use my laptop when
I'm not at home and I use my desktop
when I am at home and and I kind of like
pushing stuff all the time but I don't
want to push broken code to get up
because it's just not like I don't
really want to do that I kind of because
Sparky is a public project I pretty much
just want to keep like these commits
here nice and clean
to an extent right stuff that isn't
finished yet but does work or at least
doesn't break the API or the engine or
even compiles right
that kind of stuff I'll happily push
here but stuff that I'm working on
comprehensively and I just don't want to
I don't want it to break stuff I don't
commit here now you might be might be
crazy you might be like what does that
mean you're not using a version control
system I am I'm actually using a
different version control system I'm
using a version control system called
version or okay and version err yes yes
has to be pronounced that way by the way
is a it's a pretty cool open-source
version control system here it's written
in c-sharp
it's actually written by someone you
might recognize it play hate from the
from the slack if you guys are on my
slack which you can get there by going
to like there'll be a link in the
description but it's gonna be like
slacked off the channel calm and you can
sign up there basically it's like is
like a team communication thing here he
hangs out there pretty often so you guys
can catch him on there but anyway people
I hate wrote this version control system
called version error and and it's just
really good it's just really
straightforward and it's pretty complete
actually and I just I just didn't want
to use another instance of git or
anything like that to kind of version
control that stuff so it's like it even
does service stuff like it's actually
pretty awesome and it works a lot better
than get actually but the idea is I am
kind of version controlling all that
stuff so if you guys were to look on
here for example there's like the
version a copy of Sparky like if if I
just show my log concisely here you can
see kind of the stuff that I've been
working on right and in fact they've
even got the dates here right so I've
done stuff like I've implemented the
Disney and Jade reacts diffuse and
specular brdf models respectively I've
done stuff like shadow mapping and debug
menu stuff I'll show you guys all these
features in the end in just a second I
just wanted to kind of show you the real
kind of commit log of stuff that I've
done since the last dev vlog I've done
like I saw even started the third
rendering it's been a lot of stuff as it
has gone in here a lot of PBR stuff I
started I BL so image based lighting and
I fixed a bunch of pretty serious engine
bugs as well so that's kind of what I've
been working on and I'm gonna go through
it now but if you guys feel free to
check out version I it's pretty cool
pretty easy to use and and I quite like
it more so than here in fact
okay cool so let's take a look at with
the engine and let's take a look at and
what I've done so if I just launch it
right now
by not opening properties then you will
see this okay now this looks kind of
terrible in a way the only thing that's
terrible about this really are the
shadows because they are noise City
right now look at look at how noisy
those shadows are anyway I'm not really
focusing on the shadows I just kind of
slapped them in there in about an hour
or two I think just to get stuff looking
kind of all right and mainly just so I
could tell how high objects were off the
floor but the main thing I've been
working on it was physically based
rendering so you can see for example
it's actually a bit difficult to see
here because these are all white but you
can kind of see a bunch of spheres here
with varying roughnesses okay so this
sphere for example you can see the
specular highlight is kind of softer and
more spread out because this surface is
rougher than something like say this
which is a very kind of tight rough
surface and the specular highlight is
like that
and if we were to look at this crate
kind of this terrible crate texture
we've got on the floor and I bring up
the debug menu and I just the roughness
on that you can kind of see how the
roughness of the material effects you
know the specular highlight now this all
looks very kind of dark and dull right
now and of course this like the
roughness the smoothness of these
spheres is almost it's not really been
shown to its full potential because
there is no image based lighting right
because obviously in the real world and
in fact in this once I get around to
actually finishing it what you would see
here is this would actually reflect his
environment right the smoother an object
is the more it reflects right and even a
grazing angles you would see like the
for an owl and you would see the
inflection of of the environment and of
course there is no such thing as the
environment right now well that kind of
is but I'll get onto that in a minute
but there's no there's no such thing is
that just yet because I haven't liked my
shadow right now does not do any kind of
image based lighting things right so
it's kind of not there yet it will be
there hopefully this wake up I'll put it
in there
one thing I added to the de baak menu as
well and I know you can say this textile
and it looks terrible but anyway one of
the things that I had to this debug menu
is the ability to
not just the just single values like
this roughness but you could just give
it a vector and you can see you get
three things so if I want to for example
change the cubes position you can see
that I can just move like these
respective sliders around and it will
adjust the x y&z position right and the
same way with for example the light
position so if I move the light around
so this is a just a dynamic point light
by the way the shadows are actually
coming from a completely different
unrelated directional light because I
haven't done point like shadows yet
because they're pretty hard to do but
you can see how that light kind of moves
around and the roughness on the on the
cube is actually a little bit different
than the roughness on then this
roughness I think the cube has its own
yeah you can see that as I move that the
cube hasn't change because if you and
the cube has its own roughness but
anyway you can kind of see how that
works so it's pretty cool it's you can
chuck in like a vector of x3 or a vet
for into the debug menu and just adjust
it just like that it's really really
easy to do you can see how that kind of
gets close to the point light but yeah
the shadow mapping that I implemented
was kind of all right the two things I
have to do is obviously like soft
shadows and clean up this terrible noise
that I'm getting from all the
randomisation that I'm doing with the
samples but also like shadow cascades
and all of that stuff needs to be done
so this the shadows weren't really not
the focus again the shadows was just me
being like you know what this thing
would look a lot better if I spent an
hour putting shadows in and I just
slapped them in there and they're in
there right so don't focus too much on
the shadows I know they look pretty
terrible they work which is nice but
yeah again they don't look they don't
look 100 don't look that great so so
yeah okay
so let's also talk about the other stuff
about it so yeah I've gone over PBR
basically I've gone over the debug menu
stuff and then the other big thing I
think that I really added would have
been the I added a bit of an FPS camera
as well as the Maya camera so you can
kind of do that in fact fly over a bit
of scene and I just changed this to be
an FPS camera you can roughly see what
I'm
meant by that so now you can see I can
kind of move around as if this was like
you know an FPS kind of thing I'm using
WASD and then I can do that so that's
just a different way and it captures the
mouse and everything that's just a
different way to kind of move the camera
so my camera is still I think a lot
better for moving around and stuff
because it's kind of mimics Maya and in
general it's just nice for viewing
objects and getting up close and
personal with some of these things
oh let's actually put the plane back on
because I that I've got like a bit of a
like I think it's a make seventeen or
make fifteen like World War two ERA
fighter in here because why not and you
can kind of see how I just cuz that's
more or less a real object and you can
see how that looks
let's see if I can adjust the light
position as well so yeah I think the
roughness on that as well as based on
this slider yeah so you can kind of see
it again it doesn't really make much
sense now because first of all this
plane has zero textures and second of
all there is no image based lighting
else so there's nothing for turf like
there's no environment okay cool sir the
other thing I wanted to mention it was
yeah so I added there are a few things
that have changed as far as textures go
right textures now there are different
types of textures that are there's a
texture interface which kind of has just
the base kind of interface for textures
right and you have stuff like you know
bind unbind stuff that all textures have
right and then you've got three
implementations of textures right three
different types of textures you've got a
texture 2d which is kind of your simple
kind of traditional 2d texture that you
would you know render your diffuse
channel from and and that's pretty basic
and then you've got your cube texture
which is a like a cube map right and
eventually we'll go flow that from a
single file but you can also load that
from multiple files that's how it works
right now and of course it generates all
the cubes and the MIT maps and all that
stuff I mean the MIT maps are actually
something I need to add to texture two
days as well and then you have stuff
like texture depth which is just a death
texture right
and that's used for things like shadow
mapping wait where you want to just
output like you just want to just want
to store the depth of something right
which is like just one value not you
don't want like rgba or RGB or anything
like that okay cool so that's how that
works and this is just right now a
sixteen via depth so that's how that
cookie crumbles um what was the other
thing yeah
so to see that in action if I open my PB
Yoshida which is right over here we can
do a few things so if we just set the
college would be something like a
texture look out for you environment
which is what I've set that to we can
probably just look at the normals I
think that would kind of be alright so
you can see that sampling from the cube
actually that's gonna look terrible let
me just quickly reflect that by wheat I
have to be negative I as well alright so
now we kind of have just a normal kind
of reflection right for sampling it and
you can kind of see how that cube map
works with that in mind right and it's
pretty cool and then we have if I really
wanted to spice it up I could kind of
show you my IBL thing that is literally
half done so what this will do is it'll
figure out the it will essentially
figure out that reflection vector but
and then determine a mid level based on
the roughness right so basically it is
nowhere near complete right now it's
actually like half implemented but
basically all that means is that you
will be able to like it'll set the mid
levels it all said like how polarity the
texture is pretty much based on based on
her office surfaces okay and obviously
reflect it as well so there off of the
surface the lower quality texture is
going to sample basically so that
results in like it doesn't look the
worst I think because in this case gotta
get that stuff going on but if I was to
increase the roughness or something you
would see that and this is gonna look
really weird but you can see that when I
increase the roughness these clouds for
example this
a good thing to look at these clouds
kind of just get really blurry and
eventually you'll be able to see that
the seams of the texture cube and anyway
just a cool little thing that is kind of
half a half implemented right now but
you can see how that works so anyway
that's pretty much it I'm gonna wrap up
this devlog right here because I don't
have too much else to say you guys
should definitely hang out on the trail
on the Trello thing I added two new
things which was FPS camera all three
things FPS camera and then GL fw i want
to bring back GL FW for OpenGL right
because I'm going to have to use GL of W
anyway for web so we might as well not
have a specific Windows I I'm still not
sure if I want to keep that but I
definitely don't want to do platform
specific like windowing code for Mac and
Linux because I really don't care too
much about those platforms to be honest
so I'll get GL of EE to handle that for
me and that'll be nice so yeah and
probably Windows as well and then I'm
definitely gonna look at getting DirectX
11 going for Windows for stuff like
direct input as well or X input and of
course direct3d 11 as well because
direct3d is a much nicer than OpenGL and
to be honest OpenGL has just been
frustrating me a lot lately because it's
very difficult to debug and it's just
generally not no where near as elegant
as direct3d 11 anyway that's that
hopefully I'll be able to once this PVR
stuff is done I'll definitely commit it
to the github repository so you guys can
definitely check out that code and
hopefully it works on my platforms as
well almost hardware but yeah that's
what I've been working on so this is dev
vlog number 3 I hope you guys enjoyed
and I will see you guys up one more
thing let's just get everything out of
the way here so apart from checking out
github almost forgot about this apart
from thinking about apart from checking
out github and Trello you're gonna want
to follow me on twitter as well it'll be
a link in the description and if you
truly enjoy seeing this and you want to
see more of this and I'll definitely
start coming out with some actual
tutorials on how to do some of these
concepts like shadow mapping and PBR and
all this stuff once I get it implanted
and working properly and deferred
rendering let me quickly show off
deferred rendering because I just forgot
to do that I've just done the basics for
that
if we go into was I doing go into scene
right
no where's this this would be in lay 3d
this is currently in here it won't be
for much longer but if we use the
deferred renderer and we have to specify
a width and height all I'm doing here is
I basically set up MRT is right model
multiple texture mild multiple rendered
textures right I've set up multiple
render targets sorry that's why I man so
you can see we're outputting like the
diffuse here and then the normals here
and then the UVs here and the position
here we don't actually need to output
the UVs of the position we can kind of
get them this is the J buffer and we can
essentially recalculate them later
I'm just outputting them right now
because I've got I don't I don't have
anything else to output yet because
again I haven't kind of finished PBR and
there would be other useful things that
we can output but basically that's kind
of where I'm out with deferred rendering
and I will definitely continue working
on that but I want to get the PBR so
I've done first so that at least I have
like a proper you know forward renderer
that will be able to kind of look
beautiful and and then from then on you
know I'll kind of probably move on to
stuff like deferred rendering so anyway
if you do enjoy this stuff and you want
to support me then of course I do have a
patreon account here so you can pledge a
certain amount per month again there's
Sparky rewards I'm gonna have to start
maybe I'll give you guys access to like
a diversion I actually that's a good
idea maybe I'll give you guys access to
that secret version of repository of
Sparky so that you can get like
essentially nightly builds actually
that's a cool idea that I literally just
thought about then maybe you guys will
get maybe the people who pledge like
five bucks or more per month will get
access to that version repository with
the kind of super-secret stuff that is
kind of nightly builds and then github
commits will be kind of official almost
releases where I'll still all commit
stuff that is not necessarily broken so
yeah that would be a good idea actually
so go ahead and and become a patron so
anyway thanks for watching guys I hope
you enjoyed please hit like button if
you did enjoy this video and I will see
you guys next week with another Sparky
dev vlog
goodbye